what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
then I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer the official one for frozen
to hopefully it's a you know not
confusing and we get a clearer idea well
we're actually hopping into this do it
okay I'm following like this movie's
gonna
[Music]
weird to you she seems like Elsa Elsa
whoo
[Music]
the kingdom is not safe
I'm setting it away who is calling to
you they may have no excuse me I climbed
to North Mountain survived a broken
heart and thank you for my ex-boyfriends
though you know I'm coming we're strong
character
where are you sterling hey around
Internet boys yeah
[Music]
damn themes
magic is a lorry without you see bad
news
oh sweet that's a really unique design
with that a lot of my goodness they did
one of those like sweeping shots of that
trailer man it's beautiful well we got a
better idea of the plot here this time
around and the themes yeah I mean it
starts off there talking about this
enchanted forest no can you in or out of
this place and it must hold the secrets
to Elsa's powers in some way yes and
then when when arendale Riverdale you
know comes under attack
CW threatens to not renew them for
another season heredad and Arundale
comes under attack you have to venture
off to this mystical place and it looks
like because you got sterling gate Brown
having a line at one point saying
protect arendelle at all cost so I
imagine that somehow else is able to
clear the mist
yeah whatever God with her staff
whatever is disharmony is it's going on
in these woods it's attack in arendelle
she's got the key to dismantling or
defeating or whatever then yeah but
somehow it relies on the people that are
in there too because they said like
within the forest they practice and the
magical stuff right everyone's talking
about magic when I'm with Elsa there
yeah magical forest I get the impression
that else is gonna be on her own by the
end of this movie because they looking
at frozen one it's a lot of Elsa and uh
developing a relationship forming that
bond again connecting and then it was
sisterly bonds that have been crushed
for so long this when you make a point
you go into this boys in the first one
it's about sisters coming together and
in this one there's so much of you know
Elsa being pulled to this other you know
just origin story of herself yeah and it
just seems like she has these people
that she probably belongs with and so
much of the trailer is Anna wanting to
come in and help Elsa seems like she's
very reluctant to it so I imagine part
of the letting go theme my deal with
Anna having to let go of her sister by
the end of it it's funny because I'm
loved
- trailer had a kind of this similar
thing potentially yeah I mean from this
trailer I'm grabbing a whole lot of
different sisterly vibes again that
almost seem like they want to be
stronger than the first frozen because
the first frozen was all about kind of
them kindling this relationship they
spend so much from the movie apart and
then finally the end they come back
together and save each other and this
one you know you have that theme of like
you can't just chase me into fire and
then honest says well you can't just go
running off into fire so partly this
almost suggests to me that maybe there's
gonna be some kind of plotline about
Elsa learning to maybe not be so
reckless in her approach to things and I
don't know I mean I don't know if she
would ultimately wind up on her own or
if there's gonna be some kind of
independence that struck but there's
gonna be a moment where we think she's
gonna be on her own
once you know else was about to leave
for the plane she gets off the dance
rides back to their car and then is
sterling K Brown is he gonna remain a
good guy till the end or they gotta pull
another love it was real love interest
my answer yeah for Anna she's totally
gonna have an affair this is gonna get
real dark Disney you know oh yeah and
Kristoff is gonna be so heartbroken and
he's gonna go off on some kind of bender
and he's gonna become the real villain
team-up whatever is destroying Erindale
if you want to come here for accurate
predictions this is the place this is
the place to come to Walt Disney they
must have a really good idea up their
sleeves because they said they weren't
gonna touch frozen unless they had a
dynamite ideas so I'm hoping for that
well this feels a lot more sprawling the
word epic has been thrown around so much
for what these like for the marketing
has been doing for this movie and yeah
like that's the best word I think to
describe what's been going on with every
image we've been getting like yes there
seems to be a lot more peril seems to be
a bit of a heroin journey it's
mysterious still in its plot it's crazy
how you finally get the official trailer
where you think you're gonna get a
clear-cut storyline it's a lot clearer
for sure but there's a lot of mystery to
be held how big of a role will Olaf
plate
no yeah you know I mean ugly enough he's
not really that prominence to this
trailer or any of them you'll get
another cute marketable character for
this movie I think it might be the horse
yeah the water horse the water horse or
the ring that'll last likes two minutes
that other water horse is awesome yeah I
know I mean the thing is especially the
animation is that much more breathtaking
I mean the first frozen looked amazing
but they've taken that not obviously one
step further here and yeah I mean on the
scope level it definitely looks like
it's matching and then trying to exceed
the first frozen cuz I remember the
first frozen it has a pretty scopic
adventure to it some pretty amazing
designs especially with all the ice
formations and it definitely looks like
they're notching that up for this I mean
the first frozen I thought was a really
fun Disney animated movie this one feels
a again this is another term that could
be loosely applied these days but it's
the first so that comes to mind feels
like it could be more on the
storytelling level of perhaps a Pixar
movie because it doesn't seem like it's
anywhere near as goofy as the first one
it doesn't yeah it definitely I think
that's why it's just all with the
marketing masks some of that up this is
a coaster market because even though
they because they do have Olaf in here
but he's like all the other fun
characters already played for a comedic
effect but nothing like the really goofy
stuff just being played up all here so I
feel like there's gonna be a lot more
moments to take this serious unless of
course I walk into the theater and oh
never mind it's a laugh a minute thing
this is your traditional Disney musical
movie everything does look a little bit
like oh man there's some peril coming in
yeah it looks like some actual threats
will we have as much whimsical fun or is
this is gonna be like the grownup
version of Froome no no this is none of
the triggers that made me like laughs no
it's really made me feel light I think
feels very heavy even like my
anticipation of the music I'm like all
these are gonna be like pretty heavy
songs right yeah they have and speaking
of the musical and hurling kate brown's
gonna sing a tune that could be cool I
mean he's arguably the thing I'm most
excited for partly because he's just got
such a toys or walk on your
location right here uh-huh yeah just
like when we're gonna get some black
people who throws in let's get some you
know Hispanic and some Asian actors and
frozen's all I want in this clearly
Scandinavian town mr. Lee K Prime has
such a distinct voice its second you
hear one word yeah that's great man now
let's see if this will be the highest
grossing animated movie of 2019 or will
it be a live-action version of lanky hi
it's busy movie are you part of that
hype train for frozen to make a comment
below what do you think is gonna happen
in this movie subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell see
get notified whatever forgot a YouTube
video up you can check us out on patreon
where we do weekly Q&A s TV show
reaction stream along some shows of
reaction highlights included Ito's music
video coverage weekly I'd like to end
this with a patron today shout out to a
lovely woman named Rosa Parra the lady
Stark of our channel yeah she's on
cherry-picks now she's on cherry-picks
John tell him about it's like the female
Rotten Tomatoes lots of great different
female critics voicing their opinions
and you know what Rosa you're killing
the game with your views element
Instagram you got your own site and
you've got a really good insight so
seriously go check out Rosa's reviews I
actually just watched book-smart
recently because I was inspired by one
of your reviews Rosa you've played an
influence on my life for quite some time
at this point and you continue to be one
you know we admire the living hell out
of you doing our favorite people in the
world that we love you say hi to your
family for me I love you you're the ELSA
of our channel and I'm your Olaf mmm
your spend mm-hmm so who's Kristoff in
this metaphor
Tyrone magnetar